第1回らんちゅうパッカーシーケンス19
で今回の司会進行を bmc ケンプで4つとにさせていただきます只見そうです
よろしくお願い致しますみなさんアンチパってご存じでしょうかいう名のファンの
シリーズなんですけども
この記事の中に具材が入っているパンの種類なんですけどもこっちラインで説教色んな
お店から買いまくってきて多分全部
方も全種類のランチバック集めてきたつもりでございます寺島ってどんな
のかというと口の中に具材が入ってるんで見た目は全部パックて一緒なんですよ見て
多分全部一緒だと思うんだよねまあ色ってやっぱり模様ついて行ったあるんですけども
ほいっしょなんと全部具材を確認しないと全部一緒なんですよ
これすなわちフォローアップと一緒なんですよ素晴らしい噛み合ってるでさあにねこれ
がすごいことに
さてのランチパック2枚入ってるんでもうホラーと
シュナンでペアでこいつらは入っとるつまりこれを風も開封して5番ままって一人何度
に並べると進呈衰弱できるんですよとだけども見たいが全く一緒なこのランチパック
なら出来るであろうランチパック神経制作
今日はやっていこうと思いますでライガーもよってもまず開けていきま
これに感謝も折り目ついてるからね中国凝然よというすれ違う
会津ゲー10分でました多少の色の違いはあるもののなんか大抵はほぼ一緒ですねこれ
じゃないどれ
終わったら人生
まあとりあえず25種類ありませあの味なんですけどもいちごジャム&マーガリン袋
プレップトリプルふたっつ
big ベリージャム雨54種のおいしいサークちょっこ
ブルーベリージャム頭が悪いメイプルしが埋まり子マヨネーズハムエッグハム飢えたに
クリーミーコロッケ
きなこミルク束マヨカレー焼そばちょこれーと鶏そぼろマヨネーズふじりんごジャム
のカッターのいいなんてごろっとフルーツのヨーグルトクリームオペランド曲がり市
マヨネーズ見込みで3ハンバーグ
以上になりますどうぞ地獄のようなルールなんですけどもう今からバーって混ぜて
もらって何なんでわかんないようにします
僕が2つ選んで食って同じ味だったらその2つは終わりです2つが違う味だったら違っ
た2つが丸付けた
されていくって感じであーめっちゃたくさん買ってやるんでもう僕は2つの女王当てる
までずっと食い続けなければならないというワンちゃんしますそんな地獄のような
ゲームですが何しパックにも魂はあります見てねが一緒でも違うその個性をしっかりと
私が生み出すことができればきっと出ませんはずや早速混ぜてもらいましょう
シャワーんっ
[音楽]
し混ぜてもらいましたーーー
まあ
やべえなこれでは早速やっていきましょーあのまずは明らかにこれがセットなんですよ
あず違うするこれにかしたい種類しかなくてもやむを得ませんこれが多分あるです4
種類の美味しさって4つ阿字観ってやつですねハッハー
熱いを多くすぎというのありますよね勝たせていただく
まぁあれだけで邪魔者は排除いたしましたじゃあもう逆には加齢性や柄によっていき
ましょうかもう良材でキーのですよこう絶対そうですねはい
パッタいたぞ入ってんだけどこれはいこっちゃばらないんだチョコ
ポツンバナナいたところでクリアーです
色味はわかりピュアその後23種類ですたらここからはマジで6月お説教するんだよ
なぁ見た目したねってないんですけど食っていくしかないんで恨みから察するにまず
これかなとこれ食べてみます
なんだこれいやーこれむずいな煮込みでにハンバーグ感あるんですよ
絶対ハンバーグやこれやと膨らんでるのはここに来なんでこっちなき月な食べてみます
あっ違うのか断面店でごめんなさい色が全然違います
50倍デーにクリニクロって言うと見込みでにハンマーですね
うう
うわぁネッツ生かせますやばやっぱ背負ってからこれは山下に国見とって
見込みデミハンバーグで開きましょうにくい心言ってみろとハンバーグ超ここらへんな
気がしますねグリーンプロでねと食べてみます
あっハンバーガーでレーザーな女はこっちだった気がするな
いやほっ
かほっちます
店頭1んぞ煮込みてみハンバーグクリアーで安全塗った皆様ごめんなさい
このゲーム1回のミスが命取りだななん子ぶってるんだろうまだこんなにあるのに結構
釣ってるんですけど
だが当てればいいんですどんどんやっていきましょう
じゃあこれはピン跡のマークついてるんですけど裏もうっすらとピーナッツのマークが
見えるんですよ
伝わるかなグッズだとピンと甘くみるとこっちももちろんいますけどこっちにもこれ
ピーナッツ確定ですねフィーナツイ近く
めぐるのアリですかああそうですよね数が20年あのめくれの愛にさせてくださいこれ
無理ゲーすぎますそれメイクにょれ知らないマークあるんだけどね
かマークであっはいはいピーナッツ確定です
パンクリアできたありがとうございます
うまえよないけどはお腹すいてる時に食べなかったねどんどん有馬署
一個しかないんだけどこれもう無理じゃんローズかな先にちょっとサイロや使って
みようかん
4種的に茶色で使わせます
いただきます
明日いたツボが入っているのはから多分ダークチョコだと思いますねこそはやれるかね
板長が入っていることは査証のか誰でも分かるはずだと思います
ジャージャーがランチパック結構仰望5は1万円で結構腹に来るんですよこれ
もういらんです嘘でこれあたり funny クリームだったはず俺いきましょうこれ
でたにクリームだったら今クリアなんで
このぼーんいやのプレビューも牧師で分かるところだけクリアせて順調にいってるん
ですけどこっからがまず修羅なんてね全部一緒やどう攻めるいきます
[音楽]
ピーナッツ集スーダンきなこか
あっお前からは半分のような匂いがした
お前が生臭い何か撤廃はないお前もダイナ
こんなペア構えながら謝るの俺
ぱっぴーなっつほれ多分これですえっ
なんだこれは何かがわからんこときな粉ミルクだそしてお前
ああああああ
アイダホメルクリアですやもう
up a よああ風景だ結局音匂いで何とかなると思うんですよ
生臭いの前をなぜ匂いを考えを必ず行けるためここな気がすんだよなぁできます
鯖マヨだか構えを
あっはぁああっああああああ
シンプルに縦ねこれでもうここは確定なんですよね
はぁ
アップラウンドエッジで歌って本当ヨナがいっぱいあと全部白いシコブシのいっすよ俺
が立ってるのってこれ蟹クリームコロッケくらいなんだよな
じゃあこれはこんな遊びで切れてしまった良いが頼りだということを
[音楽]
あったこれブルーベリーだこれブルーベリーです
これはこれ見ろほれみろ
違うなイチゴ茶目だこれこれはいつはザマンドマーガリン決着へどうぞ増刊それ
歌も焼きそばターン今日はなぁん
いやー
はカーンなんでだこれがすげー馬鹿な奴だったらにゃん
あっはっはこれだーーーっ
黒い当たるはこれごろっとフルーツのヨーグルトクリームですね
人生終わったそしてここで税金です20%引き書いてある通りなんですけどめっちゃ数
が少なくて
巨乳2足とくればもう残り何もしませんこれは食べかけのまでゾッドさせていただき
ます申し訳ありません数に限りがございますので
イチゴっぽい匂い当てればいいんだから
これだ多分これ食べてみます
運搬だよ子連れグレーやなぁと一致ゴーグルビルでしょ
ブルーベリー
[音楽]
青いな
わー
分かりません微妙に色が違うんですよこっちのブルーベリーでこっちが多分一番ねサー
例も1回のミスで覚醒しましたこれが市場ザメですね
パーンと音がた優れでしょブルーベリー探しますは不安マン
たっ半径がこれ練習スプレー処理それてみます
はい
ウッキナっぽい夏菜はやだツナマヨ
津波やじゃないのこれツナは jota ません
君だはい
ん
[音楽]
ブーバーこれだ
んだ紫蘇がはい
もう本を1本がこわー
ユーメディアで大
[音楽]
おれオレだオレが多分ます
おっはー
[音楽]
バーン
チャーハン風10番拷問やはもう無理だしてません胃袋が限界でしたらひとついえるの
はまあ結構待つやってはいるんですけど
山で特価カツサンド系と勝手に良いとか大きさが全然違うんでそこらへんは結構分かり
ましたねこっから先の中に要因に個性がないというか結構真狩レベルの難しさだと思う
んですよねこれは
何も感じるも tektro に食ってみるか持っています
[音楽]
ビンゴじゃんとかスターだったので行けるはこれなら
俺だ凝っちゃったこれやと向かってる大食い
[音楽]
me
バッハ
結論から言いましょうねすごい楽しかったんですけど一人あでもじゃないですねだって
一人で50枚くえんも相手受けてなんかみんなで行ったら凄い面白そうだなと思いまし
た結構なが頭使えば会えるんで年が普通の神経性弱よりいろんな釣り技福祉すれば
うまいことできるような気がしました皆さんもぜひやってみてください
畑のみんな